hello there every gamer can tell you a
story of a glitch they encountered from
Game ending defects to hilarious moments
that completely break the laws of
physics today we are looking at 20 of
the most iconic glitches in video game
history Assassin's Creed Black Flag is
all about life as a pirate on and off
the open Waves yet a glitch could cause
this to happen as you approach your ship
a hole in the water Where Your Vessel
should be stranger still is the
possibility your crewmates would be
stuck in Perpetual Free Fall above it
eventually this glitch fixes itself and
it becomes even more epic the sunken
ship Rises to the surface effortlessly
for an accidental glitch that is
beautiful one of my favorite glitches in
video games are thanks to the wheelchair
NPCs in cyberpunk 2077. inclusivity is
quite important but the coding on all
NPCs is to run away if there's ever any
danger so if you decide to interact with
this guy this will happen the flea
mechanic takes over and magically his
legs work again it's a miracle or maybe
he was just faking it I can't believe I
have to say this but please don't try
this in real life
over in Five Nights at Freddy's security
breach a glitch was discovered that
duplicated the animatronics hunting down
the player in the dark by skipping a
certain section of the game the Monty
character Manning the light in the
atrium would multiply and the moment a
player was spotted by a security bot the
entire horde of gigamontes charged right
to the player
absolutely petrifying let's look at the
game less frightening Hitman 2 a game
that lets almost any item become deadly
in the hands of Agent 47 but nobody
expected this to happen when the
briefcase was thrown okay it takes a
little bit more time than I expected
you've just gotta wait
yeah the Homing briefcase was born the
developers were quick to remove this
error but thanks to players absolutely
loving this it was actually made into a
mechanic and those devs recreated the
glitch and now it's a permanent item in
game the new homing briefcase doesn't
move as slowly as the original but it's
still possible to throw and watch it
chase down a Target to this day oh I
love it fortnite has been packed with
glitches for years from spinning
chickens to Invisible heads my favorite
was thanks to this item called the
inflatable a protective sphere in the
theme of a cow made for getting around
the island safely players found that by
activating the item at the same time as
picking up a teammate caused the downed
player to slightly increase in size and
then by repeating this the character
continued to grow of course we took this
glitch too far and made a character so
big they broke the physics of the world
and began falling upwards
[Music]
surely a game like Microsoft flight
simulator can't have game breaking
glitches can it well yes as it's
possible to find black hole style
creators around the world if you're
going to Brazil be sure to look around
this bug was so common the community
began attempting to fly into the hole
and land successfully under the world
one of the first video game glitches was
found in the Pac-Man arcade cabinet and
this is what it looks like luckily
average players like you and I will
never see this in real life as it
happens on level 256 as the screen
memory fills up the data spews onto the
display corrupting everything
in Detroit to become human it's possible
for entire characters to despawn leaving
only their eyes behind floating in the
air like this freaky yet no other
character in game reacts to this they
must see it a lot another visual glitch
is found in Battlefront the Star Wars
online shooter lets us play as iconic
lightsaber wielders but nobody expected
this lightsabers can completely vanish
suddenly Darth Maul looks like he's
pretending to use a double-ended saber
like playtime at school
sometimes new patches can break games
rather than fix them which happened to
Skyrim back in 2011. for no reason at
all the sacred dragons in the world
began flying backwards two weeks later
the patch was reversed and the legend of
the backwards flying lizards became a
story told Through the Ages flying butt
first does make a lot of sense
Battlefield has had many iconic glitches
Through The Years yet Diner saw a man
from the Battlefield 3 beta is the most
memorable I honestly can't put this into
words what am I seeing right now
a glitch which never got patched out is
found in heavy rain a chilling story
about a father trying to save his son
Ethan Mars is searching and we can shout
out his son's name
oh okay so far long story short the
glitch makes it so we can shout Sean
anytime we choose including during cut
scenes which kinda makes these serious
scenes really silly
the long-running FIFA Series has been
riddled with bugs and glitches over the
years in FIFA 14 a glitch was found that
made every player's hands enormous
including the referee to get this to
happen the ball is booted out of play
and then this seemingly random list of
inputs are quickly pressed resulting in
this Abomination I don't know if I'd
call this a glitch or a hidden feature
the other version of football with the
padded dudes and an egg is a sport you
wouldn't expect many glitches in yet in
Madden NFL 15 the Tiny Titan glitch made
players so small it's tough to see them
but heck this guy can tackle the Madden
series even made a video laughing at
themselves and brought in the player to
play along and give the Tiny Titan a
backstory so not many people played the
reboot of Saints Row recently which is
understandable when you see this glitch
in a huge important scene to the
storyline we have to survive a quick
draw Face-Off on the roof at dawn yet
this actually happens
foreign
this is why QA is so important in gaming
not even the perfect
Man games can escape glitches in
Spider-Man Miles Morales it's possible
to play as spooderman the dude with the
long neck and the reduced Jaw from the
picture swinging around saving the city
the glitch was surprisingly simple by
selecting a suit and holding the cancel
button at the same time the suit the
suit would default back to Peter
Parker's from 2018 giving miles a suit
he should not have access to and thanks
to their difference in posture miles's
head didn't quite look right and
everyone quickly realized he looks more
like spooderman I'm not saying that the
perfect glitch exists but this is close
to it look out here comes
one of the most iconic glitches is
thanks to a simple texture swap in
Mountain blade a medieval role-playing
game it's possible for the sky texture
to be replaced with this a face in the
clouds above staring down emotionless I
don't know about you but I think this
kinda looks great did you know about the
Among Us glitch that made players
invisible the first one was found in
free mode by venting at the exact same
moment as the oxygen levels deplete but
then a public invisibility glitch was
found as an imposter we'd vent just
after an emergency meeting was called
it's got pretty tricky timing but when
done right as soon as the next round
begins you're free to hunt your prey
completely invisible wait it wears off
after you take out a crewmate well this
is awkward probably the worst glitch of
all time happened in World of Warcraft
array debuff made to make endgame
activities extremely tough somehow found
its way out of the raid activity and
into a server's capital city where
thousands of players congregate safely
suddenly Lee it wipes them all out over
the course of a few hours skeletons
began to litter the streets everyone was
perplexed surprisingly wow players
thought this was an amazing event to be
part of when in fact it was a glitch in
the system a bug in the software and
finally the most iconic of video game
glitches Pokemon's missing no from
Pokemon Red and Blue after gaining the
flyability at the start of the game and
then surfing this island Coastline a
random encounter will bring up this
enemy to face you a glitched Pokemon
like no other things get even weirder if
we run away from the fight it would
actually duplicate items in our
inventory completely free so some
glitches are good and this also confirms
that there are 152 original Pokemon
after all you should totally like And
subscribe right now and here have
another video to watch this one's a good
one I'll be back next week with another
episode see